Paul founded several,
probably small house churches
in the area of Galicia.
Uh, there's some debate about exactly
what part of Asia minor he's referring to
because there are different parts.
They were called Galicia. Uh,
and of course the word
Galicia you recognize probably
just comes from the word
for gall. That is the people
who occupied France later.
The Gauls,
uh,
were tribes that tended to be in different
parts of Europe at different times.
So there's part of Asia minor
that is modern day Turkey,
the central part of it that was
called Galicia after the goals.
So Paul was there at some point.
We don't know exactly when he
founded some churches there.
These were all gentile churches.
There's no record at all that he had
any contact in the area with Jews
themselves. And there's no record in the
letter of glow to the Galatians that, uh,
he's addressing Jews at all in the letter.
It's,
if you notice from the letter also,
it's not directed simply to, um,
one house church are even one town.
Galicia refers to an area that
included different towns. And so it's,
this is something like a circular letter
that would have been gone around to
different parts of that.
Other traveling teachers obviously have
come along and at some point and quite
reasonable enough,
they may be themselves be Jewish
followers of Jesus or they may be gentiles
themselves, but who became law observant
when they started following Jesus.
And this will be natural. I mean,
if you come along and say, well,
you're now worshiping the god of Israel,
now you're sort of claiming
to be followers of Abraham,
your claim to be children of Abraham.
You're claiming to be followers
of a Jewish Messiah. Well,
it's okay that your followers,
and it's okay that you were baptized,
but if you really want to be
a full citizen in this group,
you need to get circumcised like, uh,
other Jews do. You need to keep kosher.
You need to follow the Jewish law,
this,
the Jewish ethnic laws or are written
for Jews. They're still in force.
And if you want to be a part
of the people of Israel and,
and follow the god of Israel,
then keep the Jewish law
a perfectly natural idea.
But it sends Paul way over the edge.
So he writes Galatians two,
this group,
trying to convince them
not to accept this,
what he calls a new teaching
or a different gospel.
And this is where Paul is in his most
angry and most vituperative of just about
all of his letters.
And we're going to go through several
parts of it because what I'm going to
point out right now is how
did Paul try to convince them?
So look at Galatians with me.
We're going to skip around in several
parts at two. Galatians two 15,
the first part,
first two chapters you've already read,
because we read at the very
beginning of the semester.
This is when Paul tells the story
of where he was in Jerusalem,
where he was in Damascus. He
how he got his own Gospel. He,
his independence from the leadership
of the Churches in Judea. Uh,
Peter, James, John,
precisely because it may well have
been that the people who came to the
relationship after he did,
and we're teaching these people,
otherwise they might have
said, well, you know, Paul,
sure he told you some of the Gospel.
But Paul's not really one
of the original apostles,
the original apostles or
Peter and James and John,
and we represent their point of view.
So Paul initially set separates
himself from that, uh, at all and says,
I didn't get my gospel from Peter,
James and John.
They are not the core apostles.
I'm just a much in a possible as they are.
I've got my gospel straight from
Jesus. But then he goes on to say, uh,
to talk about the law to 15 we ourselves
are Jews by birth and not gentile
sinners. Gentile centers was just like a
two words that almost automatically went
together in some Jewish
rhetoric and propaganda.
This period that being outside of
Israel, being outside the people of, of,
of God was made you a center
practically in itself,
at least according to some points of view.
And then g and Paul tends to share that
point of view because he uses gentile
sinners himself more than once.
Yet we know that a person is
justified not by works of law,
but through faith in Jesus Christ.
We have come to believe in Jesus Christ,
that we might be justified by faith in
Christ and not by doing the works of the
law because no one will be
justified by the works of the law.
But if in our effort to
be justified in Christ,
we ourselves have been found to be
sinners. Is Christ then a servant of sin?
Certainly not. But if I build up again
the very things that I once tore down,
then I demonstrate that I'm a
transgressor for through the law.
I died to the law so that I might live to
God. I have been crucified with Christ.
It is no longer I who live,
but it is Christ who lives in me.
The life I now live in the flesh.
I live by faith in the son of God,
for if justification comes through
the law, then Christ died for nothing.
It's a pretty big
statement. If CR, if you're,
if the law get you anywhere than
Christ didn't need to die at all.
Notice what he says in three 12, he
gets even worse. Um, with what he says,
three 12. The law does not
rest on faith. On the contrary,
whoever does the works of
the law will live by them.
So notice he's separating out faith and,
and law.
That's not something that almost any
Jew would do. The idea that somehow,
uh,
you don't have faith in God because
you keep kosher is ridiculous too.
A lot of Jews, right? In
fact, you're keeping kosher.
You're keeping the law is an
expression of your faith in God.
And so Paul is saying this is,
it might sound almost commonsensical if
you've been raised in a Christian Church,
but if you put yourself in the mind of a,
of a Jew in the first century,
hearing this somehow that the law and
faith are opposed to one another is just
very shocking.
Look at three 15 brothers.
I give an example from daily life.
Once a person's will has been ratified,
no one adds to it or a nose.
It,
the promises were made to
Abraham and to his offspring.
It does not say and to offsprings.
And what he's doing,
he's playing on the Greek word seed is
what is translated here, his offspring.
And he's saying this was
given to Abraham seed.
And the Greek word is singular seed.
It doesn't say seeds.
So that means that, uh, it has to refer
to Christ. Christ is the seed of Abraham,
not all the people of Israel.
My point is this,
the law which came 430 years later,
does not,
and all a covenant
previously ratified by God.
So as to nullify the promise for if
the inheritance comes from the law,
it no longer is from promise, but God
granted to Abraham through promise.
Notice what he's doing here.
He differentiate, differentiate
the law from promise,
which would be very odd
coming from a Jew at the time.
So separating off the law firm faith,
separating off the law firm promise is
counterintuitive in Jewish theology at
the time.
Uh,
and then what he also says is the law
came 350 years after God made his first
covenant with Abraham. Abraham just, I
mean, God justified Abraham by faith,
although he was circumcised
later with a circumcision,
was not what justified him. Uh, it was his
faith that justified them, even Abraham.
So he takes all the way back to
the father of the Jews and says,
God made a covenant with Abraham.
The law came 350 years later.
So the law is a late comer in the whole
s and the whole system of how God was
dealing with people. Then look at what
he says in three 19 right after that.
Why then the law, in other words, if
you had the covenant with Abraham,
why did the law come about anyway?
You didn't need the law to have the
covenant according to his theology.
So he says, why then the law, it
was added because of transgressions,
until the offspring would come to whom
the promise had been made and it was
ordained through angels by a mediator.
Now this is really weird.
The law came about for transgressions.
Now there's a way to,
uh, to a couple of days you
gotta understand this, did the,
and the way most modern Christians read
is the law came about to keep people
from sinning. You know what you're
not supposed to do by reading the Law?
So they'll all comes back to
keep you from transgressing.
But I don't think that's what Paul's
doing because price precisely in Romans
five 20 when he makes a similar statement,
it's very clear there that the law
came in to increase transgressions.
What he's saying here is somehow the law
came in after the comment was already
established and it was precisely brought
in through a much later and it was
added to increase sin in the world.
It's a very odd thing to say. Notice what
he also says. It was ordained by angels.
I've talked about this before when
we talked about the speech of Steven.
Paul is saying that God even wasn't
the one who gave the law to Moses.
It was given by angels. What
he says, look guys, his, um,
it was ordained through angels by a
mediator will, who is the mediator? Moses.
Right now a mediator involves more
than one party, but God is one.
That's odd,
but it seems to express what would
have been sort of a legal theory in the
ancient world. For example, if you have,
if I want to sign a
contract with all of you,
we don't have to have a mediator.
You basically just choose one of you
or a committee of you to represent you.
And I represent myself. If I want
to sign a contract just with Jude,
then we don't need a mediator.
We just signed a contract together.
But if you have two groups of people
wanting to come to some kind of agreement
to have a contract,
a covenant,
you need a mediator who can be in the
middle and not represent either of their
interests, but be neutral.
So what he's saying is that
there's a mediator here, eh.
All the Jews know that,
that Moses was the mediator.
But if the contract was between God,
if the law was between
God and the Israelites,
you didn't have to have a mediator.
And he says,
that's precisely why they
had to have a mediary.
It wasn't between God and Israel.
That's it was between the
angels and the Israelites.
Notice how demoting this is
of a certain piety of the law.
You believe the law came 350
years after the covenant.
It was given by angels to Moses,
not even directly from God,
and it was given in
order to make sin worse,
not to make,
not to get rid of sin.
Look what he says in three 23 he's
digging himself deeper though he's saying
more and more negative
things about the Jewish law.
Three 23 before faith came,
we were imprisoned and guarded under
the law until faith would be revealed.
Now the law becomes a prison guard that
keeps humanity and he sees me talking
about all of humanity, not
just Jews. Somehow the law,
the Jewish law in put all of humanity
in prison and kept it there all those
years.
Look what he says in three 24 therefore,
the law was our disciplinarian
until Christ came,
so that we meet about might
be justified by faith. Well,
the word disciplinary
in there is that word,
the Greek word pedagogue.
Does anybody have pedagogue in your
Greek translation there at three 24
does anybody have a different translation
at three 24 then disciplinarian?
Yes, sir. In the back,
what does three 24
therefore the law was our,
okay. Was put in charge. So if someone
in charge it were first to the slave,
because these were almost always slaves
who took care of young boys when they
were going to school.
That a child would,
up to a certain age
would be into the care.
And obviously you were talking about upper
class people who had slaves and could
and would put their children in
the care of nurses and slaves.
The child had a very young age
would be under the care of a nurse,
but at a certain age, maybe five or
six, the child, the boy especially,
they would be put in charge of a slave
who basically was assigned to watch over
the kid. The pedagogue, contrary to the
way this has come English as pedagogue,
didn't refer primarily to the teacher
of the child. That was a different term.
The pedagogue was a slave who just
basically took care of the boy,
made sure the boy, uh, carried the kids,
uh, uh, books to school, had the tablets,
the wax tablets they wrote on and
that the blocks they wrote on, uh,
kept the kids stuff in a little Satchel.
And watch the kid took the kid to school
to make sure the kid got there safely
and make sure no older boys were bullies
or make sure the kid didn't get any
trouble and then stayed in school and sat,
maybe sat in the classroom.
I sat outside the classroom until school
was over, then took the kid back home,
make sure the kid did his homework. And
according to a lot of Greek literature,
pedagogues are not only are they slaves,
they're ugly.
We have lots and lots of artistic
representations of pedagogues in ancient
terracotta and that sort of thing.
And they're usually depicted as ugly,
stumped slaves and they're often depicted
as mean and cruel and they beat the
kids all the time.
So by calling the law a pedagogue here,
I don't think Paul is saying
that the law was our teacher.
I think what he's saying is
the law is that slave, uh,
surviving who kept us basically enslaved.
Remember he just said we're prisoners.
Look what he says in four three.
So with us,
when we were minors,
we were enslaved to the elemental
spirits of the cosmos of the world.
This term, elemental spirits goes back
to something I talked about previously.
I think it was in my lecture when I
talked about Steven's speech and x.
This is that Greek word strike chaos.
Okay, is a very, very big major Greek
word. It can use in all kinds of ways.
For one thing,
it just referred to ranks of soldiers.
If soldiers were lined
up in different ranks,
those ranks were strike Kia rose.
It could refer to all kinds of other rows.
It could refer to letters of an alphabet
that could be talked about is star k
because what you do,
you put them,
you put all the letters of
the alphabet in a row and you,
and there are different elements.
So Start Kia also can refer to what
we would call a chemical elements.
The element, the table of elements. Those
will be called star, Kia, and Greek.
So for example, they took wind, fire,
water and air are sometimes
there were other for earth.
Sometimes you've heard this a theory,
right,
that the Greeks believed and ancient
people believe there were four fundamental
elements of all matter.
And those are sometimes they said six,
sometimes eight, sometimes
others, but quite often they'd,
they'd settled on for classical elements
and they believe that everything was
made up of some combination of
earth, fire, water, and air.
And so everything's some matter.
Those are the thicker stuff,
has more earth in it and less air.
The lighter stuff has more
air in it and less earth,
but all matter is made up
of these four elements.
So these elements
constitute the whole cosmos.
But what's really interesting is at least
a lot of people in the ancient world
believe that these also,
this term also referred to this sort of
angelic or demonic or godlike beings who
constitute the universe also.
And their words,
they didn't believe necessarily
that air was simply an ERT material.
It also was a god or some
kind of demonic being.
So,
or some people would say that each of
these different layers of the universe say
the layer that is earth or the layer
that is water or the layer that is air or
the top layer that is fire or ether,
that those are all
divine beings themselves.
Or they could talk about them as
being not divine beings themselves,
but being ruled by divine beings.
So they, even Jews for example,
would think that there were certain angels
who were in charge of different rows
of the universe. So for example, if
you, and this is what we talked about,
gnosticism, if you want it to go
to God according to some, uh, uh,
magical texts,
for example,
you had to figure out the tricks to go
through the different ranks of demons or
angels that lived in the
sky between you and God.
And one way to do that is to
learn secret pass a passwords.
So magical text I'll sign often will
give you what it looked like, passwords,
because we had this password.
And when your soul is flying up to God,
you can give the password to whatever
demon or angel is guarding different gates
between you and God.
So these steroid Kayah refers to elements
of the universe in a physical sense,
but it also refers to these spiritual
beings that rule the cosmos or even make
up the stuff of the cosmos
and a lot of ancient thought,
but now notice what Paul is saying here.
When we were under the law,
we were enslaved to the elemental spirits
of the universe being under the laws
being enslaved to these and he says,
you want to go back to that
slavery but wait a minute,
what are the Galatians doing?
They're not saying we want
to go back and serve idols.
What Paul is saying is
when you serve idols,
you are actually serving the
strike chaos of the universe.
They weren't real gods, they were
fake gods. You just don't kind of,
angelic beings are demonic beings.
Paul,
I think believed they were
real beings behind idols,
but they were demons or something like
that and the store k out were those the
Galatians are not wanting to go
back to idol worship apparently.
What are they wanting to do?
They're just thinking, well,
we're going to keep the Jewish law,
but Paul,
not they equates keeping the Jewish law.
If you're a gentile with
going back to idolatry,
that is radical for any Jew in the
first century to equate law observance,
keeping kosher, being circumcised
with actually worshiping idols.
That's radical. And yet that's what
Paul is doing here in Galatians.
Noticing what he does know. I'd say
that because in four, eight he says,
formerly when you did not know God,
you were enslaved to beings
that are by nature are not gods,
that is your Insulite to demons or some
kind of other like being like that.
Now I have, or that you've come to
know God or rather to be known by God,
how can you turn back again to the
weak and beggarly strike chaos.
So he's,
he's equating their attempt to keep
kosher or be circumcised with their
returning to idolatry. And then look
what he says in his little exit.
Jesus in for 21 here he has a
good 10 verses that are important.
So I'm gonna read the whole 10 versus
tell me this is Galatians four 21 you who
desire to be subject to the law.
We'll do not listen to the law.
So he's going to give you a little exit.
Jesus here for it is written
that Abraham had two sons,
one by a slave woman and
the other by a free woman.
One the child of the slave was born
according to the flesh. The other,
the child of the free woman
was born through the promise.
Now this is an allegory.
These women are two covenants.
One woman in fact, his Hagar from Mount
Sinai bearing children for slavery.
Wait a minute,
Mount Hagar and Hagar
is the slave of Abraham,
not his wife.
Sarah is the wife of Abraham,
not as slave Isaac,
who then had Jacob,
who had had Joseph and all the brothers
from whom the people of Israel came came
through Sarah,
not Hagar.
According to Jewish mythology, who are
the descendants of Hagar and Ishmael?
Pardon?
Who? Who are the, uh,
not Muslims but Arabs.
Yes. Cause not all Muslims, but
according to Jewish mythology,
Arabs are the ones who descend from
Hagar and Ishmael, not the Jews,
but Paul Equates Hagar with Mount Sinai,
which is the mountain from
which God Moses got the law.
Why does he see neck Hagar who
represents the non Jews with Sinai,
which represents the law. You would think
it would represent Sarah with Sinai.
Yeah.
Now Hagar is Mount Sinai in Arabia.
Okay.
And corresponds to the present Jerusalem.
The Jerusalem.
Sarah should correspond to Jerusalem.
Yeah,
for she is in slavery with her children,
but the other woman corresponds
to the Jerusalem above. Oh,
and now he gets another Jerusalem. Now
there's some kind of heavenly Jerusalem.
That's what represented by Sarah.
She is free and she is our
mother for it is written.
Rejoice you child is one who bear.
No children burst into song
and shout you who endure.
No birth pangs for the children of the
desolate woman are more numerous than the
children are the one who was married.
Now you my friends are
children of promise like Isaac.
Now he's talking to gentiles
here he's not talking to Jews.
He's saying you gentiles are children
of promise. You're connected to Isaac.
But just as that time,
the child who was born according to the
flesh persecuted the child who was born
to the spirit. So it is
now also, wait a minute,
it seems like he's accusing the
Jews of persecuting non Jews.
Followers of Jesus.
What does the scripture say?
Drive out the slave and her child for
the child of the slave will not share the
inheritance with a child of
the free woman. So friends,
we are children not as a slave,
but other free woman.
Drive out the slave woman if
he's equated the slave woman,
Hagar with Mount Sinai,
with Jerusalem in Judea,
it seems like he's equating
the Hagar with the Jews,
at least the law observant Jews.
And he says, drive them out.
That is very radical now.
And then finally he ends up
later in chapter five, verse
four. Then I'll move on.
You who want to be justified by the law
have cut yourselves off from Christ.
You have fallen away from grace.
Notice he's not saying that you're going
to fall away from grace if you sin.
That doesn't seem to be the
problem. He's saying, if you,
even if you gentile followers of Jesus
even attempt to keep the Jewish law,
you'll be cut off from the grace of God.
That's radical
and it's no wonder that all this
stuff got Paul into trouble. Now,
we don't know what happened with
Paul's letter to the Galatians.
We don't know whether he convinced them
that he was right and the other people
who are coming, uh, telling them, teaching
them to obey the law. We're wrong.
We don't have second Galatians
unfortunately, or any other letters.
It has been pointed out by some
scholars that Paul never talks about the
collection that he later takes up,
which among his different churches,
which I'll talk about in a minute,
he never talks about that in Galatians,
nor does he ever mentioned the area
of Galatians again to any of his other
churches in other areas, and that's
led some people to suggest, well,
maybe Paul lost the battle in the
churches of Galicia and therefore he just
didn't deal with him anymore. After that.
We have references in his other leg,
in his letters to churches
in a Kia like current.
We have referenced to his leg
to his churches in Macedonia.
We have referenced to churches in Ephesus.
We have referenced at different churches
that we know Paul founded churches,
but we don't ever have any reference
elsewhere to Galician so somebody would
have said maybe he lost the battle.
Maybe he lost the argument in.
That's why we don't hear any more about
it, but we don't know that for sure.
The letter though, if he Paul winter
on teaching this kind of stuff,
it clearly though got him in trouble with
other people who just thought not only
was this wrong,
but it sounded antinomian.
It sounded anti law in general.
And that leads us to Romans.
So now turn over to Romans.
Romans isn't written in a
very different situation,
but let's first just see what just Paul
tell us what does Romans tells us about
Paul's reputation with regard to the law.
Look in Romans three eight
okay.
Now in chapter three he's talking
about a lot of different things about
justification by faith, apart
from law, but just in verse eight,
I'm just going to take a clue at her.
But why not say as some people
slander us by saying that we say,
let us do evil. That good may come.
Their condemnation is deserved.
Ah,
Paul denies the charge,
but is it very hard to imagine why some
people who may have heard about the
kinds of stuff he says about the law,
the law was brought into increased
transgression and then transgression
increased so that God could
have more grace and mercy.
Doesn't that sound like Paul is saying,
let us do evil. So that good may come.
Apparently some people thought it did.
So Paul brings up the
charge and denies it,
but it shows that Paul had
already developed by this time,
some kind of Antinomian reputation.
Notice what he says in Romans six
six chapter.
What then are we to say,
should we continue in sin in
order that Grace May abound?
It sounds like that would be
the logical outcome. Paul,
you've just said several times
that as sin increased in the world,
grace increases more.
So let's send,
we're not saved by doing good anyway.
We're not saved by following the law,
so let's just ignore the law
and sin and grace will abound.
Paul again seems to be echoing something
that could have been very logical
charge against him. How does he
answer it? By no means, how can we,
who have been heck, can we who
died to sin, go on living in it.
But here he goes on to answer the charge
and the rest of chapter six by saying,
by coming,
by being bed peasant to Christ,
you have so vacated
the whole realm of sin,
that it's inconceivable that you could go
back to it as long as you're in Christ,
you can have nothing to do with
the whole world of sin. So he,
he gets rid of that charge.
But we can see that some people saw that
there was a logical connection between
some of the things did and
said in places like Galicia.
So he has to deny he does the same thing
in six 15. What then should we sin?
Because we are not under law, but under
grace. He says, no, no, no, no, no,
no by no means.
That's not what I mean.
But you can see how he got the accusation.
And then, uh, in three 20,
some of the other places he
talks about the law in Romans,
for no human being will be justified in
his sight by deeds prescribed by the law
for though the law for through the
law comes knowledge of Sin. Ah,
so you can hear Paul's gears working.
He's trying to nuance some of the
things he's saying about the law to too.
So doesn't sound quite as radical as
he had sounded in Galatians entity may
likely have sounded elsewhere. So right
here say he admits there for that.
Well the law is good for some things
through the law came knowledge of Sin.
So that's, that's a good thing. Look what
he says in three 21 right below that.
But now apart from law,
the righteousness,
righteousness of God has been disclosed
and it is a tested by the law and the
prophets. Ah, so both the
Torah, the law and the prophets,
at least bears witness to
the righteousness of God.
Because if you'll notice throughout
both Galatians and Romans,
Paul quotes Jewish scripture more than
it is in any of his other letters is
precisely when Paul's dealing
with problem of what is the name,
what is the relationship between non
Jews to Jewish law that Paul actually
quotes Jewish scripture the most?
And that's in Galatians and Romans.
So here he's saying,
he's saying we can look at the law and
the prophets to learn about this doctrine
of righteousness that I'm now saying to
you, because the law will attest to it.
It's a much more positive view, the law.
And he also says, we uphold the law,
uh, by this, by doing
this, uh, look at, um,
yes, it's three 28. Uh, look at three
27. Then what becomes a boasting?
It is excluded by what law? By that
of works. No, but by the law of faith,
for we hold that a person
is justified by faith,
apart from works prescribed by law or
as God that [inaudible] Thee is God the
God of the Jews only is he not got
her gentiles. Yes. Also gentiles,
since God is one,
but the last verse of that chapter,
do we then overthrow
the law by this faith?
You would have thought from things that
he said in Galatians that the answer to
that would be yes. By no
means. On the contrary,
we uphold the law.
And then look,
one more place here. Seven,
12, Romans seven, 12.
Okay.
Uh, he says backup one,
verse two, verse 11, for sin,
seizing an opportunity in the commandment
deceived me and through it killed me.
So notice what happens here.
Sin Is talked about this as
this agent of the cosmos.
Sin is almost like one of
these sort of strike kr,
kind of like an intelligent being.
This is actually a debate
among scholars of Paul.
Some people really believe that sin is
a high pasta ticed intelligent being of
some sort in the cosmos.
Other people say, no, no.
Paul's talking metaphorically when
he talks about sin and these words,
and we need to see sin,
uh,
not as this actual hypothesize being,
but simply a metaphor.
Metaphorized as of being.
So scholars themselves debate about what
Paul means when he talks about sin as
this agent,
but at least he talks about sin as the
agent who uses the commandment uses the,
um, where was I at? Seven. 2012.
Yep. Okay. Where was
I? We're just reading.
Okay.
Seven 11. Yes. Sin. Seizing an
opportunity. The commandment.
So sin uses the commandment to,
to see the human beings and kill them.
Paul's not talking about
himself personally. Here,
he's talking about himself
as representative. All
human beings today says,
so the law is holy and the
commandment is holy, ingesting good.
Doesn't it strike you that that is that
little addition of verse 12 doesn't seem
to follow so logically from verse 11
how can the lobby holy ingesting
good if it's deceiving people?
That part clearly going on as Paul is
backing off the more radical things he
said about the law and trying to nuance
this, and that's the question I'll ask.
So let's read the rest of that for
we know that the law is spiritual,
but I'm of the flesh is verse
14 sold into slavery under sin.
I didn't understand my own actions
for I do not do what I want.
I do the very thing I hate.
Now, if I do what I do not want,
I agree that the law is good,
but in fact it is no longer I that do it,
but sin that dwells in me for I know that
nothing good dwells within me that is
in my flesh. I can will what is
right, but I cannot do it for,
I do not do the good I want, but the
evil I do not want is what I do. Now.
If I do what I do not want,
it is no longer I that do it,
but sin that lives within me.
So I find it to be a law that
when I want to do what is good,
evil lies close at hand for I delight
in the law of God in my inmost self.
But I see in my members another law
at work with the law of my mind,
making me captain for the law of
sin that dwells in my members. Well,
all of that is very confusing
and if you want to get a phd,
you can do the x Jesus off
it for the rest of your life.
But the main thing I'm pointing out here
is that Paul is being very careful to
nuance a straight forwardly negative
depiction of Jewish law and say that,
well, it's still good. In
a sense it still is true.
It's still holy and he's doing this
because I think he knows that he's got a
reputation as being anti
law and being antinomian.
So why these differences between
Romans and Galatians? Well,
we need to understand a little more
about the Roman situation first.
Paul did not found the church in Rome.
It grew up on it's own by other people.
According to church tradition, Pete,
according to Roman Catholic tradition,
Peter the Apostle Peter
founded the church in Rome.
But that's tradition and we don't have
any historical data to really prove it.
But, and I personally believe that
probably the church in Rome was started by
anonymous Jews who happened
to hear about Jesus and,
and went to Rome and then started a
little house groups of Jesus' followers on
their own. And then apostles later, just
like Paul seems to have gone there later.
But the Roman church at the pint time,
Paul is writing this letter is by this
time no longer a purely Jewish group.
They now seem to be predominantly Jen
pile with some Jews in the churches in
Rome also.
And remember,
we're not talking about one church
building or even one house church.
We're talking about probably several
different house churches that met in
different people's houses or in their
apartments and tenements and these sorts
of things. So maybe some of them
had more Jews in them than others.
But the overall church in Rome
is by now apparently gen pile.
And when Paul writes Romans,
he directs his rhetoric to gentiles.
He does say hello to some Jews in
the last chapter. He greets them, uh,
Jews who are there that he knows. But if
you look through the rhetoric of Romans,
more and more of US scholars are convinced
that the main recipients of Paul's
rhetoric is supposed to be
gentile believers in Jesus.
So what, why does Paul write this letter?
Letter? Several different reasons.
Not just one.
For one thing,
he can't write like he's written most of
his other letters as talking to a group
he founded. He can't talk about himself
as their father in the faith in that way,
he can't set his ups up as their apostle
in a straightforward way because he's
never been there at this point.
He didn't found the churches there.
So he's writing a letter. This one of the
very, very few things we have of him. Uh,
the only a letter perhaps
where he writes to a church,
a letter to a church that he himself
didn't found. So that's important.
So what do we find out? Why is he
writing it? Look at 15, Romans 15,
22.
This is the reason I have so often
been hindered from coming to you.
So he's wanting to go to Rome,
but now with no further place
for me in these regions,
I desire as I have for many years to
come to you when I go to Spain for,
I do hope to see you on my journey and
to be sent on by you once I have enjoyed
your company for a little while.
Paul sees himself as the
apostle to the gentiles,
as Peter was the apostle to
the Jews. So why not? I mean,
he didn't found the church there,
but if he,
he believes that he's already done
all this missionizing in Asia Minor.
And Greece is kind of ironic for Paul
to say this because what did he actually
done? Christianity wasn't
this big movement with
thousands of people everywhere.
It wasn't even like there was a
Christian Church and each city or town,
but Paul seems to act like these, he's
done everything you can in the east. Yep.
Everything in Greece and you know, Asia
Minor. My churches are all doing great.
I gotta get Outta here. My work here is
done. And so he's taken off to the west.
It's kind of exaggerating, I think just
exactly what he's, he's accomplished.
But in his mind, by planting a few, you
know, house churches in major cities,
he's sort of done the first
job of evangelization that
he saw himself called by
God and sent out to do.
So.
Now he's looking to the west
and he wants to go to Spain. Uh,
and so he's gonna stop in Rome. No
sizes. I want you to send me on that.
Greek actually means
that he's asking them,
he's going to ask them for
financial contribution.
Sending him along is not just,
Hey Paul, don't let the door hit
your butt on the way out. It's a,
it's sitting him along with money.
So what he's doing is saying,
I want a little contribution from you,
so I want some support from you both
symbolic support and financial support.
So that's what he's writing to them to
talk about is further mission to Spain.
He's writing him also because Rome is
the center of the Earth for uh, you know,
the Romans and for many people.
And so he's the apostle to the
gentiles or the whole earth.
So what more likely place for him to go
than to Rome at least sometime on his
way to Spain. So that's one thing
he's doing. Look also at, um,
we'll keep reading there at 15,
22 for I do hope can see
a verse 25 at present,
however, I'm going to Jerusalem
in a ministry to the saints,
a liturgy.
He's,
he's taking some help to what he
calls the saints in Jerusalem.
The sanctus means the holy ones. He's
probably talking about believing Jews,
Jews, and Judy and Jerusalem who
believe that Jesus is the Messiah.
So he's taking them some kind of a
help too for Macedonia and Acadia.
Remember the where his churches and Philip
Pie and Fessel, Annika and Macedonia.
His church in Corinth is
in a Kia master and a k.
I have been pleased to share their
research sources with the poor among the
saints in Jerusalem.
They were pleased to do this and indeed
they owed to them for if the gentiles
have come to share in
their spiritual blessings,
they also ought to be of service
to them in material things.
So he's taking money that he's been
collecting in his different churches that
are gentile churches. Pat Back
as a gift to the poor, uh,
followers of Jesus in Jerusalem,
the Jews.
So when I have completed
this and if delivered to them
what was being collected,
I will set out by way of you to Spain.
And I know that when I come,
I will come in the fullness
of the blessing of Christ.
This collection was much
more important to Paul then.
A lot of modern Christians seem to
think it's just kind of, you know, Oh,
well all churches take up money.
But remember Paul had agreed when
he met in Jerusalem with Peter,
James and John and other people that he
would go to the gentiles and they didn't
have to circumcise it installs.
Peter would go to the Jews,
but the one thing they
said is remember the poor.
And so this was interpreted that in the
different churches that Paul founded
among non Jews,
he would continue to take up financial
contributions to send back to Jerusalem.
This was partly just of
course they were poor there,
but it's also apparently seen by
Paul as very symbolically important.
The giving of money from
the gentile churches to the
Jerusalem churches would be
an acknowledgement by them,
by the gentiles of the
somewhat superiority,
at least in time in the Gospel,
they got their Gospel from the Jews.
It's an acknowledgement of the importance
in this [inaudible] of Jews in the
Jesus movement by gentiles
and it's also reciprocal.
Remember I talked about,
we've talked about the
patron client structures and
we've talked about gifts and
people giving things to other
people in the ancient world.
The whole Patriot constructs, we very
much centered around giving and receiving.
So if I give you something,
you're indebted to me.
And if you don't want to be shamed,
you have to give something back to me.
So giving and receiving is always a
very important issue with status and
relationships and friendships
in the ancient world,
whether you're talking about equals our
people on different social statuses.
So Paul, setting up the relationship
between the Jerusalem, the Judy churches,
predominantly gentile and his gentile
churches that he's founded as a,
something like a patron client structure
where the Jews gave the gentile
something,
the Gospel.
Now the gentiles owe it to the Jewish
followers to give them something.
So he's taking this collection.
So Paul has,
he's talked about this collection
and several of his letters.
It's been very important to him. And so
he's on his way to Jerusalem to do this.
But now notice what happens.
We don't. We know about,
a little bit about Paul's last trip
to Jerusalem as it's depicted in acts.
How does acts portrayed?
This? Paul goes to Jerusalem.
He's got some gentiles with him. He's
got some other dudes with him. He's in,
he goes to the temple purely
to pray to be a good Jew.
Other people not believing Jews see them
there and they think that he's trying
to bring gentiles into the
temple. So he's arrested. Uh,
he tried and then he has to eventually
appeal to Caesar to get to Rome.
What does acs tell us
about the collection?
What happened to the collection in acts?
We don't know.
The writer of acts
may have known about this collection.
It was certainly one of the most
important things to Paul and his ministry.
The writer of acts tells us nothing.
Notice also,
Paul seems to be a little nervous
if you read between the lines,
because what happens if he's collected
all this money and he takes it to
Jerusalem and the Jewish leaders say,
Paul,
do you know what kind of rumors had been
flying about what you're saying about
the law?
Do you know what we've heard?
We're not going to take your money.
We're not going to
justify your activities.
I think Paul was concerned that the
Jerusalem churches wouldn't take his money
and that would be catastrophic for his
vision of having a United church that
included both Jews and gentiles.
He writes to the Romans partly
because he'd go into his painting,
he wants to start, you know, uh, um,
prepare the ground for a
trip to Rome and the Spain.
But also he goes so careful to explain
what he really believes about the law and
justification because I think he's
afraid of what may happen in Jerusalem.
He's in a sense trying to get the Roman
Christians on his side before his trip
to Jerusalem.
And that takes us to what's become
a new interpretation of Romans.
I'm going to do this quickly and we can
talk about it maybe more after the break,
but the traditional interpretation
of Romans was that this was Paul's
theological treatise.
It didn't have much of anything
to do with the circumstances.
Paul just kind of decided
he's going to go, go to Rome.
So he sits down and he says,
what's really my Gospel in 16 chapters?
And he writes it up.
He sends it to the churches in Rome
to present my gospel to them. This is,
this is sort of a,
a theological treatise and the main
point of the treatise is you're not
justified by works of law,
by any works.
No matter which law you're justified
by grace through faith alone.
So the big Protestant, the Lutheran,
the Calvinist reading of Romans,
set Romans as the center book
of the Bible and start that.
What it's mainly about is individual
salvation, your personal salvation.
You need to recognize that you won't be
saved by your works, by anything you do.
Not only,
you're not say by Jewish law,
you're not say by Roman Catholic
rules or not say by any law.
You're saved by putting
your faith in Jesus,
having accepting Jesus as your Lord and
personal savior or something like that.
And it's individual salvation and it's
a doctrine of individuals have Asian by
faith. That's the reason Paul wrote Romans
and that's what the central messages,
very individualistic, very
doctrinal, very theological.
That reading of Romans has been severely
challenged in the last 40 years or so.
Now people are starting to say it's not
the first few chapters of Romans that
constitute the most
important part of Romans,
which has always been the
process interpretation cause
that's where Paul talks.
Dot Tryon only about justification
by faith. Scholars have said,
now look to the end of Romans chapters
nine to 11 the latter part of Romans.
That's where you'll see what
the real point of Romans is.
And it's not about individual salvation,
it's about the relationship between the
nations. When I say gentiles number,
that's just a term that Jews used for
all the nations except themselves.
So I want to say the nations, I mean all
non Jewish people's in ancient world,
that's the way the gent
tells you the term.
And in fact gentiles is just sort of a
Latinized translation of the Greek word
nations. So when you see gentiles
in Paul's text, read nations,
we referred to the non Jewish nations.
What's the relationship of the nations
to Israel and the God of Israel?
Look at a few places.
In chapter nine Paul basically
gives this apocalyptic expectation,
even quotes Hosea saying, the people
who are not my people will be my people.
In other words,
again,
Paul is quoting Jewish scripture to
enforce his belief that at the end of time
gentiles would become people of God.
And this was common in
Jewish apocalyptic idea.
The basic scenario was the messiah
is going to come at the end,
the Messiah will bring in,
will overthrow the oppressors of the Jews
and the Messiah will bring in all the
other nations, all the nations,
the Egyptians, the Greeks,
the Romans will all come to the
temple. In Jerusalem, they'll gifts,
they'll all worship the god of Israel.
And you find this in Isaiah,
you find it in Hosea. So Jewish scripture
itself gave Jews appalls Paul's Day.
The idea that the apocalyptic end would
bring all the nations in the Osi had
already come for Paul. So that's why
he sees himself as going to get the,
the gentiles in his whole mission
is part of this end time scenario.
So what does that mean? Look at Romans
1113 I'm speaking to you gentiles.
So he turns directly to
the Romans in as much.
Then as I'm an apostle to the gentiles,
I glorify my an industry in order to
make my own people jealous and thus save
some of them for if their objection
is the reconciliation of the world,
what will their acceptance be?
But life from the dead.
If the part of the doe offered is as first
fruit is holy than the whole batch is
holy. If the root is hold it
in, the branches are also holy.
So Paul gives a theology here
of the remnant, not some of it.
A lot of the Jews have not
accepted that Jesus the Messiah.
Therefore they seem to be cut off.
They're like branches of an olive tree
that are cut off and the gentiles who are
not natural branches of the dollar tree
had been grafted in their place that
needs they're part of Israel now,
but notice what this means
so that you may not claim to be wiser
than you are brothers and sisters.
I want you to understand this mystery.
A hardening has come upon part of Israel.
Some of the Jews don't believe until
the full number of the gentiles has come
in. That's his job is trying to bring
in the full number of the gentiles,
and so all Israel will be saved.
Wow.
All Israel. Notice he doesn't
explain how this happens,
but in Romans nine through 11 Paul
presents this magnificent scenario that he
believes was prophesied in
Jewish scripture itself,
that at the end of this cosmos,
the end of this world,
the Messiah would come overthrow
the oppressors of the Jews,
set up Jerusalem as the center of
the earth, and then all the gentiles,
all the nations would
come to the god of Israel.
They would be grafted in
to the nation of Israel.
They would worship the god of Israel.
Paul's addition to this myth is simply
that you don't need to keep the law in
order to do this.
So all the pulse about the law
is secondary to his main point,
which is you're now part of Israel.
Paul is not about starting a new religion.
There's no Christianity and Paul,
there are no Christians in Paul's letters.
You can't find the word.
You can't find the concept.
There is no Christianity or
Christians in Paul's world.
He believed that he was the apostle to
the gentiles to bring them into Israel,
to make the gentiles part of Israel.
And then as he says right here,
most widely along,
he somehow believes,
although he doesn't tell us
how it's going to happen,
that somehow God and God's miraculous
mercy is going to figure out a way in the
end to even bring all of Israel back in.
Also,
all Israel, he says, we'll be saved.
Paul is not necessarily the
first Christian theologian.
He's one of the most radical Jewish
theologians in the ancient world.
Okay, we'll stop now and
papers will be handed out. Yup.
Come up here to handle the papers.